bonjour nous sommes le vendredi 9
octobre nouvelle édition de votre
journal local sur tv fil 78 voici les
principaux titres les médecins face à la
réforme de la santé porté par la
ministre marisol touraine
patricia lefébure généraliste à
vélizy-villacoublay la demande de la
fédération des médecins de france nous
expliquera pourquoi avec ses collègues
elle s'oppose notamment à la
généralisation du tiers payant en 2018
une nouvelle église verra le jour à
voisins le bretonneux
ce sera la plus grande de
l'agglomération sur ce terrain elle
permettra de mieux accueillir les
fidèles et comme chaque vendredi retour
sur les principaux sujets développés
depuis lundi dans ce journal
le déplacement du ministre de la ville
pour de nouveaux moyens à saint quentin
en yvelines ou encore journée de grève
pour les salaires et pour l'emploi
auparavant l'actualité du jour c'est la
visite de pierre bédier le président du
groupe opievoy à saint-cyr-l'ecole ville
qui comptabilise 1100 logements du
bailleur social dans le quartier et gèle
drop pour cette première visite le
président a échangé avec le maire et les
habitants il a constaté l'état de
délabrement des immeubles un amendement
parlementaire a été déposée pour le
choix d'une organisation régionale ou
bien départemental concernant l'opievoy
un choix déterminant pour la future
gestion de ces quartiers c'est un
véritablement besoin d'une rénovation
complète et non pas de faire un jour les
mêmes qu'on un autre jour les volets
ensuite on fait désolation mais un
bâtiment n'ait jamais faite fond en
comble et je trouve ça dommage c'est
seulement quand on saura quelle
organisation nous allons avoir que nous
pourrons réorganiser les structures
j'espère départementalisée pour les
rendre plus efficiente plus efficace au
service des locataires mais je suis
aujourd'hui paralysé par ce problème
institutionnel il faut d'abord que je
règle ce problème avant de pouvoir
apporter des réponses à nos locataires
d'un art demain et pierre bédier au
micro deux williams elle pour tv fils la
chambre de commerce et d'industrie vient
de tenir ce matin
conférence de presse rendez vous pour
évoquer l'art autres la rentrée pardon
et les dossiers prioritaires la cci qui
guide les entreprises au quotidien et
qui va mettre l'accent cette année sur
le tourisme le numérique ou encore les
grandes entreprises et du territoire le
sujet est signé fanny bourdillon ce
vendredi matin le président de la cci
yvelines
gérard bachelier a tenu une conférence
de presse de rentrée
l'occasion d'aborder les enjeux de cette
année parmi elles le lancement d'un
réseau social de l'innovation hop à
ninove
on a beaucoup d'innovations sur le
territoire il ya beaucoup de grands
comptes avec des projets de recherche
développement verticaux dans chacun
d'entre eux trouver dans chaque
entreprise
notre volonté avec ce réseau open innove
c'est précisément de fédérer tous ses
membres là c'est marrant de les membres
de cette communauté
pour parvenir à créer un véritable
écosystème de l'innovation yvelinois
autre point important en cette rentrée
le contrat spot de structuration des
pôles touristiques l'aménagement des
berges et le développement du tourisme
fluvial sont au programme
l'objectif pour nous dans les yvelines
s'est créé autour de la scène une
attractivité touristique c'est à dire
développer cette attractivité
touristique autour de la scène donc sur
sur trois ans qu'on puisse créer des six
reprises sur la scène justement de
circuits touristiques qui soit
complémentaire avec les bien sûr les
et j'irai l'attractivité naturel les
territoires des villes qui peuvent être
versailles d'autres
d'autres sites comme montpellier ou
saint germain l'axé seine aurait un fort
potentiel touristique
la chambre de commerce des yvelines
espère pouvoir décrocher d'ici 2017
un label de territoires d'excellence
dans un instant nous parlerons de la
colère des médecins face à la réforme de
la santé invité de ce vendredi le
docteur patricia lefébure bonjour et
bienvenue sur ce plateau
nous reviendrons aussi dans la suite de
ce journal sur l'essentiel de la semaine
pour le moment le point côté actualités
sur la réalisation d'une nouvelle église
à voisins le bretonneux la décision
n'est pas encore officiel mais le cahier
des charges à lui était bouclé la
structure pour accueillir 800 personnes
ça deviendra le tout simplement le plus
grand lieu de culte de saint quentin
le reportage est un signe amical et demi
d'euros et le team one le projet dans
les cartons depuis plus de 10 ans une
nouvelle église de 800 places devrait
enfin sortir de terre à voisins le
bretonneux dans la zac de la remise
le cahier des charges vient d'être
bouclé les architectes devraient
travailler sur les plans du projet après
les vacances de la toussaint on apprend
encore ni une ni deux premiers coups de
pioche ni deux ni de pose de première
pierre
parce que avant toute chose il faut que
la casse qui est terminé de programmer
la zac de la remise
notre projet est un projet privé financé
sur fonds privés évidemment le terrain
on l'achète il ne nous est pas donné on
l'a même pas demandé mais mais mais on
est néanmoins partie prenante du projet
d'ensemble de la remise est donc temps
que la programmation de la zac n'est pas
finie comme opérateur privé on ne peut
pas commencer à agir
la nouvelle église deviendrait le plus
grand lieu de culte de saint quentin en
yvelines la structure comprendra des
salles de réunion pour les enfants un
auditorium de 200 places et trois
appartements pour les prêtres pour les
1200 paroissiens pratiquants à voisins
bretons les à montigny-le-bretonneux
cette nouvelle est une bénédiction la
crs est un petit peu petit pour les
grands rassemblements
on manque beaucoup de place est donc
sauf que c'est très bien voilà je serai
contente que le projet aboutisse parce
que ça fait dix ans qu'on en parle que
nos églises explose vous n'avez pas pu
voir ce matin parce que c'était une
messe en semaine mais les églises
explose et que ben je pense que vous
savez qu'on est trois clochers pour une
seule et même paroisse et qu'on n'a pas
de maison de famille commune même si
elle n'a pas encore l'emplacement exact
la nouvelle église a déjà un nom le
bâtiment devrait être baptisée saint
joseph de l'art hommisme rien que son
nom ne nous réjouit beaucoup saint
joseph le bienveillant jeu c'est assez
rond un très beau programme pour chacun
d'eux l'entourent d'entre nous et puis
pour la paroisse lancé c'est une immense
grâce c'est beau coût total de
l'opération 7 millions d'euros
entièrement financés par les dons des
fidèles
la fin du chantier est espéré pour noël
patricia lefébure médecin généraliste
vous exercez donc sur
vélizy-villacoublay vous étiez en grève
en début de semaine vous êtes aussi je
leur précise présidente de la fédération
des médecins de france présidente dans
les yvelines
vous étiez en grève contre certains
aspects de la réforme santé et derniers
propos de marisol touraine votre
ministre de tout et de tutelle c'était
sur france inter le 6 octobre
les médecins sont je cite parfois un peu
frileux face aux évolutions
ça me fait sourire oui oui oui parce que
on est au contraire tout à fait force de
proposition on n'est pas frileux on est
il ya plein de plein de choses on a
toujours prouvé que les médecins au
contraire étant par définition à
proximité avec la population se rend
tout à fait compte des évolutions de
société donc on est souvent les premiers
à demander
autrefois l'avortement les les
par exemple
et traitements de substitution pour les
héroïnomanes ses terres dont on est loin
d'être frileux alors pour vous c'est
quoi c'est de la provocation pour tester
un peu la résistance des médecins sur
sur les certains pros on va développer
la provocation c'est du déni mais mme
touraine ne veut pas entendre ce qu'on
lui dit depuis le début de l'année et
déjà depuis même plus d'un an
donc elle continue dans son dans son
aveuglement et ça nous on écoute vous
allez nous le redire sur ce plateau dans
tout cas dans un instant ce qui vous
bloque sur cette réforme est ce qui pose
problème avant de rentrer plus en
détails sur les revendications je vous
propose comme chaque vendredi à présent
dans ce journal de revenir sur
l'actualité de la semaine voici la
sélection des principaux sujets que nous
avons développée ici depuis lundi
signature ce matin à saint quentin en
yvelines en présence du ministre patrick
kanner du contrat de ville
intercommunale son objectif principal
concentrer les efforts auprès des
populations aux plus faibles revenus
l'objectif est non se mobiliser les
moyens de l'état
naturellement les moyens permettant
notamment secteur associatif de pouvoir
se développer et être utile notamment à
la vie quotidienne des habitants
le contrat de ville c'est le moyen de
rétablir l'égalité donner plus à ceux
qui ont moins une augmentation
inquiétante du nombre de plaintes pour
violences conjugales faites aux femmes
c'est le constat de la rencontre
organisée ce matin à trappes
malgré une meilleure prise en charge et
orientation des victimes grâce au pôle
psychosocial de trappes
une question reste en suspens comment on
dit gay les violences le reconnaissent
ce matin versailles de cheminots ont
répondu présent à l'appel à la
mobilisation générale lancé par les
les syndicats cgt fsu et solidaires on
veut faire des économies sont deux des
cheminots mais aussi sur le dos des
usagers
parce que ces gares fermées c'est les
gares et des trains qui sont
déshumanisées c'était postes supprimés
ces mêmes des trains supprimés par
manque de personnel aujourd'hui c'est la
situation du service public ferroviaire
sur la région parisienne
enfin les motards yvelinois également en
colère samedi ils étaient une centaine à
manifester dans le département contre
les mesures prises par la mairie de
paris notamment l'interdiction pour les
véhicules antérieurs à 2002 circuler
dans les rues de la capitale et
l'abaissement de la vitesse
parti de saint germain en laye à l'appel
de la fédération française des motards
en colère des yvelines
ils ont rallié versailles à vitesse
réduite avec nous pour soutenu que ce
top et je pense que ça lui prêt pvo
donc merci les employés d'une entreprise
de la commune de plaisir ont décidé de
fuir pour sauver leur collègue de
travail
cette affaire 28 ans et luttent depuis
un an et demi contre un sarcome une
forme de cancer
un stade très avancé il ne peut plus se
déplacer les continue de travailler
depuis son domicile à besançon
aujourd'hui ne me reste qu'une solution
la greffe du foie la page des yvelines
fête ses 40 ans l'association accompagne
adultes et jeunes handicapés
quarante ans de vie associative intense
avec aujourd'hui vingt établissements
dans les départements pouvant accueillir
700 personnes enfin ce week-end se
déroule le traditionnel festival de
bande dessinée de but que de nombreux
auteurs invités et notamment et rock
lévy noah est l'auteur des profs et
séries populaires adapté depuis au
cinéma ce qui m'intéressait le plus moi
dans la bd c'est d'inventer des
histoires de les raconter
donc j'ai commencé comme dessinateur
mais très vite dès que j'ai pu j'ai
écrit des histoires
aujourd'hui sur 50 ha nous avons 18
mille étudiants et c'est vrai que les
logements étaient très rares dont deux
sont en train de rattraper notre retard
est aujourd'hui bien sûr montigny ces
nouvelles résidences
toute l'oeuvre mais déjà entièrement
occupée ce sont cinq étudiants de 4e
année qu'ils ont créé ils en ont eu
l'idée à la fin de leur deuxième année
et vous l'avez dit floral cette machine
sert à rendre l'eau potable
elle est destinée à un usage individuel
elle peut produire 80 litres d'eau par
heure ce projet ça représente six mois
de réflexion et de recherche et environ
3 à 4 mois de création il ya peut-être
une future star de la nba qui vient de
saint quentin en yvelines
retenez bien son nom c'est tommy c'est
gore ce basketteur unis montant de 19
ans licencié au club de versailles
pourrait devenir dans les prochaines
années
le nouveau tony parker il vient d'être
sélectionné pour intégrer
pendant un an l'université de cleveland
autre actualité que nous avons abordé
cette semaine c'est la création
prochaine d'un ehpad à montigny le
bretonneux un établissement
d'hébergement pour personnes âgées
dépendantes les besoins sont importants
lc forains à manier le diwan pour ce
sujet en france plus de 11 millions de
personnes dont plus de 65 ans face au
vieillissement de la population montigny
le bretonneux avec le soutien de la
communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et du conseil
départemental prépare l'ouverture pour
fin 2010 est d'un ehpad un établissement
hospitalier pour personnes âgées
dépendantes dans le château et le parc
de la couldre de montigny le bretonneux
ce que nous avions souhaité c'est que
effectivement l'établissement les pattes
se trouve en coeur de ville pas loin
d'un certain nombre
de facilité comme une boulangerie
pharmacie va des commerces
l'objectif c'était aussi de faire que
healy et disons continuité le parc va
rester ouvert en ehpad ya quand même des
personnes qui aiment bien quand même
sortir un petit peu pour voir tout en
étant accompagné depuis ils
rencontreront balle lésigny montagne qui
se promène dans le parc 88 pensionnaires
pourront être accueillis dans cet ehpad
équipé d'un pôle médical de différents
services dont balnéothérapie et d'unités
spécialisées alzheimer l'ouverture d'une
résidence seniors de 82 logements est
également prévu la résidence services et
cet espace un peu intermédiaire entre je
suis à mon domicile seul dans un
immeuble dans une maison et puis je suis
dans un établissement d'hébergement pour
personnes âgées dépendantes
jeudi 8 octobre une réunion
d'information portant sur les travaux
d'aménagement de l'ehpad et de la
résidence service est prévue à 20h30 au
club le village de montigny le
bretonneux travaux qui devraient débuter
début 2016 dr patricia lefébure vous
êtes ici pour nous parler de votre
colère face à la réforme de la santé je
vais juste faire une petite parenthèse
parce qu'il a quand même été question de
santé dans le reportage juste avant
c'est la création des ehpad ces maisons
médicalisées
aujourd'hui en tant que professionnels
de la santé vous nous dites aussi que
les besoins sont réels
il ya une vraie demande justement pour
accompagner toutes ces personnes
dépendantes et c'est bien de voir
fleurir les structures un petit peu oui
oui oui c'est bien c'est nécessaire de
toute façon fin max est bien c'est que
c'est indispensable parce
qu'effectivement les gens vieillissent
reste en bonne santé de plus en plus
longtemps contrairement à ce qu'on
entend mais il est intéressant parce que
c'est plutôt l'inversé on entend que
l'on vit plus vieux mais pas forcément
ils sont faits à la c'est ce qu'on
entend toujours et c'est pas vrai les
gens vivent votre santé de plus en plus
longtemps mais il arrive quand même les
deux trois dernières années parce que
les trois dernières années et là ils ont
vraiment besoin d'un accompagnement
parce qu'il devienne vraiment dépendant
d'où la création aujourd'hui des ehpad 1
qui se multiplient et puis bientôt à
montigny le bretonneux on en vient à
votre actualité en début de semaine une
vingtaine de médecins libéraux qui
manifestent c'était à versailles contre
le projet doit de leur ministre de
tutelle
vous faisiez partie et vous avez déclaré
dans les colonnes des nouvelles de
versailles nos confrères généraliser le
tiers payant c'est la mort de la
médecine libérale
nous allons
notre liberté oui pourquoi d'abord c'est
je les dis mais il n'ya pas que moi qui
le dit puisque une économie de la santé
brigitte dormont qui est très proche de
marisol touraine l'a déclaré sur france
culture clairement est telle qu'elle en
disant effectivement cette fois c'est la
mort de la médecine libérale et c'est
une bonne chose at-elle ajouté et
pourquoi donc
elle l'a dit elle même aussi parce que
les médecins deviennent dépendants des
financeurs parce que le tiers payant
généralisé ça paraît jeux présentés sous
une forme tout à fait séduisante à la
population et c'est vrai que vrai que
vous allez chez le médecin vous payez
pas comme ça tout le monde peut en avoir
pu tout le monde peut consulter quand il
en a maintenant préciser le tiers-payant
ça ça effectivement à la consultation et
on mais voilà on n'avance pas l'argent
voilà c'est notre ma carte vitale et ça
se règle tout seul c'est exactement ça
sauf que tout seul ça serait cnsl
traille derrière tout ça mais bon oui ça
paraît séduisant et 11e' évidemment qui
pourrait être content quoi voilà bah si
oui il faut être contre il faut être
nous nous sommes contre mais il faut que
les patients aussi comprennent bien ce
que ça tout ce que ça comporte derrière
comme contrat quand ce contrat là même
s'il faut bien qu'on soit payé quand
même
donc c'est une passion qui payent qui
est ce qu'il va nous payer ben c'est
l'assurance maladie etc des assurances
complémentaires
henri dicton en france dit que le payeur
il décideurs et c'est quand même souvent
vrai voilà donc effectivement ça nous
met sous la coupe totale dépendance
totale des assureurs et y compris
l'assurance maladie qui pourra à ce
moment-là décidé de des médicaments
qu'on doit prescrire ou ne pas prescrire
des arrêts travail qu'on doit ou ne pas
prescrire aussi justement en quoi ils
ont ils auraient ce pouvoir pourquoi il
aurait ce pouvoir avec la généralisation
parce qu'ils ne payent pas si vous aussi
vous avez été un bonheur et un bon élève
en tout cas si vous répondez pas aux
critères qui ont été édictées on va dire
ben alors remboursés pour vous avez tout
compris
voilà voilà parce que jusqu'à présent on
est déjà quand même se met à beaucoup
beaucoup de pression on a beaucoup de
collègues qui ont été attaqués tout afin
justement pour des prescriptions dites
excessives d'arrêt de travail
donc on a déjà cette pression quand même
de l'assurance maladie de la sécurité
sociale mais bon pour l'instant ça se
résume à des sanctions on va dire
simplement là c'est carrément on vous
paye pas si vous faites plus de tant de
jours d'arrêt maladie pour telle
pathologie parce que tous veulent être
enfin le but ultime et ça c'est pareil
c'est monsieur guillaume sarkozy de
malakoff médéric qui lie très bien
expliqué que le but c'est que ce soit
tout protocole ise pour que les
assurances puissent avoir une meilleure
vision d'avenir ce qu'on peut bien
comprendre effectivement pour une
assurance et donc pour telle pathologie
ces temps durs l'arrêt de travail c'est
tel médicament
point barre quoi or les cabinets
médicaux c'est quand même aujourd'hui
peut-être le seul endroit qui reste où
vous les patients vous pouvez
être sûr d'avoir une écoute tout à fait
honnête et loyal que vous êtes sûr de
sortir avec un traitement personnalisé
c'est à dire que la même pathologie chez
votre voisin je vais pas d'un traité
paris parce que je vous connais pas ce
que vous n'êtes pas le même
environnement les mais voilà et là tout
sera à proto qu'alizé et on devra aller
dressé un tableau plutôt noir et on peut
le comprendre vu vos revendications mais
est-ce que ça va pas permettre aussi de
limiter certaines dérives certains excès
des arrêts médicaux qui sont données sur
des périodes trop longue ça existe aussi
dit pas vous mais des confrères
peut-être qui quelquefois voilà pour
facilement 10
alors ça c'est quelque chose qui est
bien que jeune centenaire bah voilà
exactement passé comme alors cette
question toujours les patients voilà les
patients abusent les patients exagère
non non non non non les ac c'est peanuts
jeudi n'a que ça n'arrive jamais qu'à
patients nous disent qu'il a mal on a
pas mal mais le principe d'une
consultation c'est qu'on fait confiance
aux gens et je peux vous dire que 99 9%
alors vous vous pouvez trouver où
certains peuvent trouver quel arrêt de
travail est injustifiée en disant moi je
serai comme ça je serais allé travailler
oui mais il ya nac et chacun n'a pas la
même personne ce perception de la
douleur de la même voie là et donc c'est
ça qui est personnalisé et que le
médecin fait mieux arrêter avec les abus
les abus sont pas du côté des assurés
sociaux ils sont pas du côté des
patients sont pas du côté des médecins
je peux vous dire qu'il ya d'autres abus
largement au dessus et qui coûte
autrement plus cher à la sécurité
sociale
on va écouter quelques habitants de
saint quentin en yvelines du département
qui nous donnent leurs avis justement
sur cette généralisation du tiers payant
et bien sûr vous pouvez réagir juste
après ça me paraît bien mais j'ai pas
difficultés à payer mon médecin non plus
donc ça me paraît bien de les payer en
direct aussi mon point vue hui ce serait
intéressant maintenant c'est vrai qu'il
ya des problématiques ils sont plus de
l'ordre des médecins
à mon avis ça leur fait un peu de
paperasse en plus quoi je pense le
presque rien qu en entendre mais bon il
ya certaines personnes ça doit sûrement
les idées je suppose comme ça évidemment
serait d'avancer les frais et les
personnes en fait qui refuse à l'eau
médecin pour payer enfin compte des
difficultés financières elles iront
elles seront soignés non parce que je
tiens à payer moi même ça va ou roux va
cet argent
et m'adresser directement au médecin
généraliste je n'aime pas les
intermédiaires je pense que la santé un
coup et qu'il faut peut-être payé
quelque chose pour se rendre compte que
tout n'est pas gratuit quoi cette
intéressante derniers témoignages qu'on
a entendu parce que monétiser les
changes avec le médecin ça permet aussi
de se rendre compte que mon père il ya
une consultation ça va pas aussi du coup
là permettent des dérives la
généralisation du terreau payant parce
que les gens vont venir vous voir
facilement se disant on paye pas en fait
allons-y je vais vous répondre la même
chose on entend ça tout le temps et
c'est pas vrai on a beaucoup entendu ça
au moment des cmu en disant balayé les
gens qui ont la cmu ils vont pas ils
payent pas ivres ont consommé beaucoup
puisque les autres ça du tout ils en ont
même aujourd'hui
oui c'est vraiment pas sale c'est vrai
c'est vraiment pas ça le problème non
j'ai trouvé que effectivement les
j'étais étonné même parce que les gens
ont l'air d'avoir bien compris quand
même dans votre interview en tout cas ce
que c'est pas le cas de tout le monde
il ya par contre un argument que que
j'entends rarement et qui n'a pas été
dit là et que les médias développe peu
c'est que je suis pas sûr que les gens
ont bien compris aussi que pour
bénéficier du tiers payant
ils vont devoir
donnez le rib à la sécurité sociale pour
que la sécurité sociale puisse rompre le
plus comment dire récupérer les fameuses
franchises qui n'ont pas été supprimés
un gouvernement gauche avait dit qu'il
supprimerait mais ça pas été le cas et
donc il faut donner un rib avec une
autorisation de prélèvement sans limites
ni de date ni de montant c'est pas
souvent et ça c'était souvent des
besoins en tant qu alors là je parle en
tant qu'assuré sociale je peux vous dire
que je vais pas donner mourir comme ça
avec prélèvement de n'importe quoi sur
moi sur mon compte par l'assurance
maladie
non pas qu'il soit malhonnête mais bon
il peut y avoir des erreurs
notre inquiétude aussi elle porte sur
l'avenir parce que vous recevez des
jeunes médecins dans vos cabinets et il
voit l'évolution la faction de la
fonction d'onde ans ça fonctionne et ça
les inquiète on va vers une pénurie les
les jeunes vont plus vouloir être
médecin aujourd'hui parce que trop
compliqué parce que pas seulement le
tiers payant mais enfin il ya d'autres
problèmes aussi mais c'est l'inquiétude
et pourquoi vous dites ne vont plus
vouloir aider mais j'ai quand même un
petit bout de temps
on est passé de 60% d'installation
libéral à la sortie des études ya une
vingtaine d'années aujourd'hui on en est
à 8 % donc une % des médecins est
effectivement alors on a mis en stage en
place par dont les stages dans les
cabinets de médecine de garage ce que
nous on demande enfin on voudrait même
généraliser à d'autres spécialités donc
ça c'est bien mais ça leur donne pas
envie alors à la fois le métier ça
passionnant à la fois les conditions des
canons travail leur donne pas envie de
s'installer et il ya de moins en moins
d'installations
hélas l'histoire du tiers payant
généralisé ça je dirais ça réfréner
dernier qui aurait bien aimé et tenter
l'expérience quand même lors des 70 ans
de la sécurité sociale françois hollande
qui dit que c'est une bonne réforme et
qu'elle va s'appliquer on rappelle le
calendrier 1 juillet 2015 déploiement
aux prises en charge à 100% par
l'assurance maladie 2016 généralisation
tout cas c'est 2017
voilà pas s'il ya plusieurs étapes mais
2017 cette généralisation tout ça pour
dire que le président va pas revenir sur
ce qui est annoncé oui enfin sauf qu'il
a dit s'il applique strictement ce qu'il
a dit il a dit que ce sera appliquée
qu'aux ce sera garanti simple et sans
surcharge de travail pour le médecin
donc si l'appli grêlons ça se sera
jamais appliquée parce que sans
surcharge pour assurer c'est impossible
donc
mais rassure elle n'a pas une énorme
confiance disent les politiques
ça veut dire vous allez poursuivre ces
mobilisations cette grève aussi commandé
deux semaines alors là c'était on va
dire un coup de semonce parce que là
c'était dans le cadre parce que la loi a
été votée enfin été voilà été voté par
le sénat qui a rejeté de toute façon le
tiers payant généralisé donc ça on le
savait mais les grands mouvements vont
avoir lieu dans un mois vers aux
alentours du 15 novembre puisque la loi
va être votée à l'assemblée nationale et
là effectivement est partout en france
des coordination des collectifs de
médecins non syndiqués se se met ce se
mettre debout et ils font beaucoup
d'action des fois beaucoup plus
virulente que dans le que dans les
yvelines
merci patricia lefébure docteur donc
médecins généralistes mobilisés avec vos
confrères ont redit contre cette
généralisation du tiers payant et vous
nous avez bien expliquer pourquoi
aujourd'hui
merci à vous nous allons bientôt
refermée ce journal le temps de vous
dire que ce week-end nos confrères de
radio sensations reçoivent la vice
présidente du conseil départemental des
yvelines en charge des ruralités call in
vino cours le fèvre au micro de nicolas
kirillovitch dans le cadre de l'hebdo
politique c'est à 18 heures dimanche
extraits vous disiez il ya quelques
quelques mois dans un article de
l'hebdomadaire toutes les nouvelles la
poussée du fn dans le département si ma
plus grande crainte
on sait que le front national fait ces
scores les plus élevés dans les zones
périurbaines et rurales on en parlait
tout à l'heure
est ce que le front national c'est
toujours votre plus grande crainte
aujourd'hui et les assises de la
ruralité c'est un moyen de reprendre la
main les assises de la ruralité c'est un
moyen d'aller voir pourquoi ça coince
pourquoi ça va pas dans les zones
rurales
maintenant ma plus grande crainte enfin
j'y vois là j'ai pas su que ça me tombe
la campagne oui c'est ce mystère que
quand vous dites ma plus grande crainte
on a l'impression que j'ai peur
j'ai pas peur mais je trouve ça
préoccupant et c'est une tendance qui me
déplaît aux sensations quant à nous le
journal revient lundi sur tv fil avec
florane parfait qui vous accompagnera
pendant la semaine il sera notamment
question de la restitution des audits
qui ont été commandés par la nouvelle
équipe politique de saint quentin en
yvelines
vous le savez en arrivant à la tête de
l'agglomération la majorité de centre
droit de droit centre droite a décidé a
souhaité savoir comment réaliser des
économies nous feront réagir les
différents protagonistes de ce dossier
puis à suivre également sur notre
antenne la semaine prochaine des
dernières avancées de la guerre des
multiplexes combien de cinéma vont voir
le jour dans le département des dossiers
sont en cours à coignières vélizy sans
compter rénovation extension des salles
de versailles du chesnay et le projet de
plaisir les salles existantes
d'elancourt de trappes de saint cyr par
exemple elles sont très inquiètes alors
que l'on vient d'apprendre cette semaine
que le multiplex de huit salles à
maurepas va devrait en tout cas obtenir
son permis de construire et début 2016
cela semble plutôt bien engagée pour ce
complexe
je vous souhaite à présent un très bon
week end vos programmes qui se
poursuivent sur l'antenne de télé filet
puis je vous retrouverai bien évidemment
vendredi prochain pour le journal de la
semaine très bon week-end donc